bonsoir ici Nicolas Toulouse qui est
c'est dans la postulat général de vous
parler depuis les vestiaires du stade
Roland-Garros Roland-Garros souvient
juste se terminer la finale des
championnats de France d'insultes sur
terre battue en double mixte
et c'est réellement un événement qui
vient de se produire ici puisque on peut
le dire personne nos histoire il y a
seulement une heure mais le couple
français Monique Chevignon et Alain
Chambéry viennent juste de battre en
Croisette la paix américaine composée de
Jimi Anderson et Laurie Patrice
entouré épuisé mais heureux j'en suis
sûr je vais tâcher les rangements
ils sont très très entourés je vous le
répète je vous propose en attendant de
revoir les phases importantes de ce
match au sommet
voilà il est exactement 17h10 lorsque
les deux équipes pénètrent sur le court
central couvert vous le voyez les
Américains sont prêts détendus alors que
les Français paraissent concentrés il
est vrai qu'il ne partent pas favori
pour cette finale des 27e championnat
Internationaux de France d'insultes sur
terre battue des millions de
téléspectateurs américains vont vivre en
même temps que nous ce match puisque il
est retransmis par satellite à la
demande des associations sport et
blasphèmes d'autres Atlantique vous le
voyez on vérifie d'abord son matériel
espérons d'ailleurs que le matériel des
Français tiendra et qu'il n'y aura pas
les mêmes problèmes qu'il y a deux ans
regardez la tranquille assurance de
Laurine et Jimmy cinq fois vainqueur de
l’american insulte Cup classée
respectivement 5e et septième joueur
mondial par l'association internationale
dans Gala de professionnels Alain
Chambéry le meilleur français
actuellement spécialiste de l'insulte
basse et du juron au-dessous de la
ceinture et Monique Chevignon qui peut
vomir son n'importe qui lorsqu'elle est
en forme c'est Monsieur courtineau
commissaire général de la Fédération
Française d'outrage et grossirt et qui
est l'arbitre de la rencontre s'il vous
plaît
voilà le premier set va commencer et
vous allez voir que dès les premiers
échanges on sait on sait que l'on va
assister à un match de très haut niveau
regardez Jimmy regardez les anges de
Jimmy
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est l'américaine qui sert la
première regardez comme à son habitude
elle est très recueillie avant de servir
elle est sourde ta femme ou quoi
et oui oui elle est faute elle est
nettement faute une erreur
incompréhensible des Américains qui est
peut-être de bonne augure donc vous le
voyez un jeu franc presque classique
durant ce premier jeu d'observation
États-Unis l'américaine va donc servir
pour la deuxième fois 0 15
tu me donnes la nausée
on dirait un chiotte à la turc ça me
donne la
et oui une petite hésitation du français
que n'a pas laissé échapper de Jimi
Henderson qui possède l'un des spots les
plus puissants du monde comme nous le
montre le ralenti
regardez la puissance de l'Américain qui
place un smash réellement un par un
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes ici au début du deuxième 7
les Américains ont remporté le premier
après la taille britfast qui a duré 1h
regardez bien ce point c'est un des
tournants du match
service Alain Chambéry France
Alain donc tous les services sont passés
jusqu'ici se lèvent ils se concentre
le jeu
une très belle montée de l'Américain qui
s'empare du filet Chambéry monte à son
tour les deux hommes se disputent avec
rage le filet on se demande qui va
l'emporter les femmes se tiennent prêtes
au cas où
et puis
et puis regarde
une magnifique série de volets du
français qui passe très fort et qui
laisse l'Américain pancourt
[Applaudissements]
il reprend toutefois ses esprits et va
tenter de regagner
et vous allez le voir
son coup ne passe pas le filet il s'en
faut on exulte dans le camp français
nous sommes ici à l'avant dernier jeu du
troisième siècle les Français mènent et
continuent d'attaquer
mais la fatigue commence à se faire
sentir
encore une magnifique trouvaille de
Chambéry qui passe bien
trou du cul
les Américains renvoient faiblement
[Musique]
15 États-Unis 0
et voilà les Américains n'y croient
manifestement plus Jimi Anderson se met
à discuter les points ici voir litigieux
et ce n'est vraiment pas dans son
habitude de contester ce qui montre bien
que quelque chose est cassé dans
l'équipe américaine
en train de discuter d'ergoter
dirons-nous des points
et voilà dernier jeu du dernier set
balle de match pour les Français
États-Unis
Jimmy
et ça attendra
[Musique]
aucune chance aux Américains
2 7 et Max c'est gagné la paire
française des championne du monde
d'insultes sur terre battu
[Applaudissements]
et bien après bien des difficultés je
suis enfin parvenu à rejoindre nos amis
Monique Alain Jimmy et Laurine alors bon
comme je sais qu'ils sont très fatigués
juste un mot Monique heureuse ah oui non
parce que faut dire qu'après le dernier
match contre les Belges enfin on y
croyait plus trop c'est vrai que les
Belges sont très fortes et voilà par
contre j'ai toujours cru enfin au début
quand Jimmy m'a placé trois fois de
suite ta gueule est con ça m'a
déconcentré mais enfin quand j'ai vu que
mes têtes de nœuds passaient bien j'ai
appris confiance et bon on a gagné mais
en tout cas un très beau match
très agréable à jouer avec des
adversaires hors pairs merci Alain et
bravo encore à tous les deux et vous
Jimmy c'est aussi ce que vous pensez un
match très correct sans incident
[Musique]
à vous Paris
je suis désolé vraiment ça m'arrive
absolument jamais j'ai buté contre le
câble dans cette vidéo parce que
d'ailleurs on devrait faire attention
avec les câbles parce que en fait
[Musique]